All-time great traveler.
No fuck!
(laughter)
that maybe the best
moment in vlog history.
I'm talking shit.
- [Male Voice] Let's go to the counter.
(calm music)
Vlog, here we are, it is 9:06
in the morning, Wednesday.
We lost all Tuesday,
you and I?
Yeah, we lost all Tuesday,
we'll get back Thursday,
or Friday, we get Friday, or whatever.
Since the beginning of the
end of this ridiculous trip,
which is, in a last week
I've gone from New York,
to Oslo, to Copenhagen, to
Moscow, to LA, to Brisbane,
to Sydney, to Melbourne,
connect in Dubai, to New York.
It's a lot of fucking travel,
but a whole lot of accomplishments,
the Complex Episode,
did you watch the Complex?
Who did that, did Ralph or you?
It's really good, really good.
Hope you get to check out that episode.
Got a lot done, got a lot
of VaynerMedia meetings in,
a lot of culture hacking,
and some great speeches
and some great friends
in all these countries.
So here is the beginning of
the, what are we here for
twenty, forty--
- [Male Voice] 36 hours.
36 hours, three locations in Australia,
epic, epic effort, so I'm excited.
Show Zach.
That's Zach, he is attractive,
but he is being inappropriate
with scheduling me this hardcore.
Zach, have you ever heard of
the marathon versus the sprint,
I mean, you gonna kill
the golden goose here.
Good to see you, man.
How are things?
You remember me, by chance?
Remind me.
Eighteen, twenty months ago,
you don't spose you remember me.
I'll remember if you tell me the story,
but faced with
Some months ago, Q & A,
San Diego, T&C conference,
I said you were super good-looking?
Yes.
Yeah, I remember. (laughs)
Toldja I'd remember.
Bout to destroy Australian Faces.
Hey, it's Gary.
Call me back.
I just wanna discuss this position,
make sure everybody's aligned on it,
and talk it through.
You guys over communicate,
and I'll make a call on Monday.
Love you, give me a call.
See ya, bye.
From getting myself hyped for a pre speech
to addressing operational
issues at VaynerMedia,
this shit can go real fast back and forth.
Stuff can change up real quick.
By the way, real fun fact.
I adore pears.
I think pears are stunningly underrated.
Do you agree?
(pulsing music)
(male voice) What if everybody's scary, V?
Super excited to be hitting
the stage any second.
Bab, and on the ones and twos.
Uh, super interested.
Have no idea what I may be talking about.
That is just basically the way I roll.
You know, improv from
the beginning to the end,
every time,
and I hope you guys enjoy it.
See ya.
(announcer) Gary Vee
(loud cheering)
I think that there's way too
many people in this audience
that are in the excuse business.
I've, and yeah,
it's tough, because
I'm empathetic.
There's always things.
You know, you could have two
parents that were drug addicts.
You could
have lost your parents in a car accident
when you were a kid.
You could have had your
money stolen to you
by a partner.
There's so many things
that happen in life.
I'm super empathetic to it.
The ultimate problem is, though
that the market,
the world,
doesn't care.
It's really interesting.
To me, life is pretty binary.
It's either black or white.
It's either yes or no.
And the one that matters to me the most
is you're either on the offense
in your life right now,
or you're on the defense.
You're either coming up
with reasons why not,
all this technology,
all this stuff,
why not?
Or, why yes?
All this technology,
all this stuff.
You're looking at things
and you're making a decision,
more importantly,
being a successful entrepreneur
is a skill set.
Right?
And, it's one that comes natural to some,
and others, not as much.
It's a fun thing to be right now,
and everybody wants to,
and the opportunity is very real.
I'm a great entrepreneur,
but I think I've even
better at consumer behavior
and psychology.
It's who I am.
It's why a lot of you follow me,
because when you cut me down,
you see that I'm pushing positivity
and a whole lot of other
things that matter.
I'm trying to get people
to do it the right way.
Be patient.
Do the right thing.
Da da da da da.
My friends,
you need to get yourself in
the right place mentally,
and then you need to get yourself
in the right place mentally.
Because the thing that people
have not wrapped their head around
is that this takes a lot of work.
Like, a lot a lot.
Not a little something.
And if you aspire.
Let me just ground this.
If you think you're gonna
make a million dollars a year,
which is funny the way
people throw that out,
like everybody gets there.
Almost nobody gets there, right?
If you wanna make $500,000 a year,
which would put you in
the just the fortunate
top one percent of income getters
here in Australia,
if you wanna make $100,000 a year
and like doing it,
and it's on your terms,
and it's your life,
it takes a lot of work.
And it takes a lot of smart work.
The thing I talk a whole lot about
is hustle.
The thing I talk less about
is being smart.
Because I don't think
that brings you any value.
So what I do is,
I try to come and speak,
or through my actions,
show you the smart things that I'm doing,
and then remind you that
it's still hard work.
The framework is simple.
This is simple.
You may have not allowed yourself
to have the honest
conversation with yourself
of how much hard work
and how much patience
it takes to be successful.
But it doesn't change the fact
that that's the case.
You've never met anybody
in your life
who hasn't worked their face off
for a long time
that's built something significant.
It may seem that it happened fast
cuz they're 27,
but maybe they've been
hustling since they were 13
in a different way
that gave them 14 years of experience
to be a winner in that game.
And so, please.
Please wrap your head around
what we're actually doing here
and more importantly,
if you were smart enough to be here today,
and I mean this,
the fact that you came here today
puts you so far ahead of everybody else
and I hate knowing,
for a fact,
that so many of you are
gonna give up your advantage
because you like hearing me say it,
and you like the way it feels,
but then you leave,
and you don't do anything about it.
So please,
do me a favor.
Go do something about this talk today.
I implore you.
It will change the course of your career.
Thank you.
(applause)
Nice and solid.
Put up vlog.
Bab and I
successful so far
Good stop on the way to Sidney
Good energy, good talks,
good stuff, good life.
(upbeat music)
I got one.
The Vayner part.
Output.
The production world at a lower cost.
All-time great traveler.
Oh, fuck.
(laughs)
That would be the best moment
in vlog history.
I'm talkin' shit.
Let's go to the caf.
Off to Sidney.
Love you.
Thank you very much.
You know, different cities,
same back of the seat.
Conversation, me and Bab,
now we're on our way to our city talk.
The weather is beautiful.
It's a beautiful city overall.
Your first Sidney trip, huh, Babs?
I'm happy for ya.
Hi, how are you?
I'm Emma.
Emma, nice to meet you.
Very nice. Is that what this is called?
We're gonna say it, right?
I can just imagine you
got coming this way?
Where were you this week?
Australia, you got Israel?
They all know how I roll.
Show you
Ha, ha, that's awesome.
I love that.
Yeah, I wanted to do something different.
Thank you.
I think I'm excited.
It's amazing to me,
There's a lot of famous people
and so many people speak so highly
of who you are backstage,
which is not always the case.
Thank you for saying that.
You're so uber cool backstage.
Thank you. Thank you.
I mean, there's not
I literally got done
just saying in Melbourne,
uh, in Brisbane,
that my entire focus is what
people say behind my back.
And to have you say that
Well, because, you know, we've all, I mean
Yeah
We've been here for 20 years,
Sure
and you get a real
And the one there is real different
I've heard
Can be, and you're someone
that you would have
around to your house,
to eat dinner with,
and just have a chat with
I appreciate ya saying that.
Thanks for saying that.
You're cool.
Zero ego, and
Thank you for saying that.
I love what you
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
I'm extremely optimistic
I'm extremely positive
what's going on,
and it's all because of the framework
of this vlog.
This thing.
How many of you do not have a cell phone?
Raise your hand.
Cool.
Zero, by the way,
For everybody in the front rows.
This thing is ridiculously powerful.
This thing is the remote
control of our society.
This thing has eliminated every excuse
outta your fuckin mouth.
Because, if you have to work nine to six
to pay the bills,
to pay your dues,
to pay your debts,
that is exactly right,
and appropriate,
and everybody comes from
different starting points
and I have unbelievable empathy to that.
The exciting thing, though
is that our grandparents
didn't have this thing.
They hadda work nine to six,
nine to seven,
and then there was only so much upside
that they could create
for themselves long-term
from seven to two in the morning.
This thing has fundamentally
changed everything
and I just think we take it for granted.
I really wish everybody understood
the power that is literally sitting
in their hands right now.
This is literally a media creation
and distribution tool
that would have cost
tens of millions of dollars
if you understand distribution.
The technology probably cost $20,000,
you know, 25 years ago.
Cameras, this, that, fine.
The distribution?
You would have had to shoot a satellite
into space.
You would have had to
buy a printing press.
You would have had to buy trucks.
You would have done so much.
The fact that every person here
can literally turn this on themselves,
create content around something
they're interested in,
and then have platforms like
YouTube, and Facebook, and Instagram,
and Twitter, and LinkedIn,
distributed,
let me remind you,
at no cost,
is so batshit crazy
for all of us old fuckers in here
that I just wish people would
not take it for granted.
And so, my friends,
I come here tonight
to really try to pull up one move.
Can I actually take somebody,
even if they're a huge fan,
or if they've never heard of me before,
and tweak their perspective
on what's actually going on.
Can I convince one of you
that nobody gives a shit
about your headaches and problems,
and when you complain,
you're just taking minutes off the board
and energy off the board,
from doing something about it.
Literally, I am fascinated
by the inability to be held accountable.
I'm fascinated
that you actually are coming up
and spending energy
and trying to say why
you're not successful
because your older brother did some shit
in 1996.
(laughter)
And so,
self-awareness and humility
and empathy
and all these warm and fuzzy things
that grandma talks about
happen to be the biggest secrets
in the rough-and-tumble game
of business.
I highly recommend
you getting in touch
with those emotions.
Thank you.
(applause and cheering)
(male voice) Thank you!
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for havin' me.
I'll make a little content here.
I'll turn this on.
All right, now really
lose your fuckin' minds
Here we go!
Go!
(louder cheering)
Love you guys!
Thank you!
How are you? Thank you.
My pleasure.
Really good.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
You enjoy it?
Yes, I did.
Love everything you do, man.
It was great, Gary.
Thank you.
You shook your head on a certain point
early on.
Yeah.
Wonder if it was about crypto,
or something,
and I saw you, and I was like
he gets it.
Oh, it was my underpriced.
I said, everything's priced appropriately,
or over-priced,
and you shook your head,
it was like, he gets it.
Take care, man.
That was a good one.
Stop. Can we stop for a second?
Yeah, I'll hop on for a second.
Oh, look, Gary.
Yeah, what's up? What's up?
What's up? What's up?
How'd Gary get here?
Hi!
Whaddup, Fiji?
Not Fiji, yeah.
You sure you got that?
Cuz I'm not sure.
Love it.
You like that?
How good was that?
Do you like the shout out?
Is that good?
See ya.
Bye guys.
Love you guys.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
Yeah?
Bab, whaddya think?
Give us a little recap.
Um, big day.
Flew from
L.A. to Brisbane,
Brisbane to Melbourne
Melbourne's near Sidney
Here, I'll take over, Bab
you stay behind the camera.
Great day, got a lot done.
Big themes,
mindset and execution,
clouds and fuckin dirt.
Motherfuckers.
Clouds and dirt.
(light music)